Tanya, get rid of her.
We decided you were
the tragic hero in the opera.
TANYA MCQUOID-HUNT:
How did I not see the signs?
In the end of last season,
Tanya is sitting with Greg
in the last episode,
and he's talking about
his health issues,
and she says...
I've had every kind of treatment
over the years.
Death is the last
immersive experience
I haven't tried.
And I was thinking it'd be
so fun to bring Tanya back
because she's such
a great character.
But maybe that's
the journey for her,
is like a journey to... death.
And not that I really
wanted to kill Tanya,
because I love her
as a character,
and obviously, love Jennifer.
But I just felt like, you know,
we're going to Italy.
She's such a kind of diva,
larger-than-life
female archetype.
It just felt like we
could devise our own
operatic conclusion
to Tanya's life and her story.
(PANTING)
-GREG HUNT: Tanya!
-Yeah. In a minute!
I just think her dying
at the hands of someone else
felt too tragic.
It felt like she needed
to give her best fight back,
and that she, in a way,
had some kind of victory
over whoever was conspiring
to get rid of her.
So it just made me laugh
to think like, she would like,
take out all of these
cabal of killers,
and that after she
successfully does that,
then she just dies
this derpy death.
And I just felt like,
that's just so Tanya. (LAUGHS)
You've got this.
(GRUNTS)
-(SLIPS, GASPS)
-(THUDS)
(WATER SPLASHING)
I think as far as like,
what happens to Greg
and the conspiracy
of Tanya's death,
it's possible that I think
Portia is scared enough
to just leave it alone,
but the fact that all of those
guys die on the boat,
it feels like there's
gotta be somebody
who's gonna track it
back down to Greg.
But maybe you'll have to wait
to find out what happens.
At the end of the show,
you see
the three generations of men,
and there's this
attractive woman who crosses,
and they all sort of
gawk at her.
You know, my hope is that
Dominic does change,
but there is a little bit
in the texture of it that
their relationship with women
is gonna always be fraught
with this sexual desire.
When she hugged me just now,
I got a little aroused.
No, no, it's a natural reaction.
He kissed me.
But that was it, okay?
That was all.
The question of like whether
Harper and Cameron
did more than the kiss,
I think probably,
that's just all that happened.
At the same time,
there's some time that
isn't completely accounted for.
And I think that that's why
it's like eating at Ethan.
Ethan comes to Daphne,
and did they have some kind of
a dalliance on the island?
Or whatever happened,
it allows him to let go
of the jealousy
that has been brewing with him.
And it kind of brings back that
first kind of sexual charge
that happens in the beginning
of relationships
and sometimes,
fades away over time.
By the end, you're like,
well maybe what Ethan and Harper
need was just a small dash
of what Cameron and Daphne have.
Thanks for putting up with me.
I love you.
It feels like Cameron, to me,
is like one of those guys
that's not really gonna change.
(LAUGHS)
Some of the unspoken things
between them,
you wonder if that's gonna
ultimately catch up with them.
It is somewhat
of a happy ending,
although there's dark clouds
in the horizon too.
The first season kind of
highlighted money, and then,
the second season is sex.
And I think the third season,
it would be maybe a kind of
satirical and funny look
at death and eastern religion
and spirituality.
And it feels like
it could be a rich tapestry
to do another round
at White Lotus.